اهلا بكم في هذه النافذه الجديده للتحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
وطبعا نستضيف المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز
دويري ونتابع اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا
على الخريطه التفاعليه مع عبد القادر
عراضه تفضل عبد القادر نعم ليلى يمكن
الاشاره الى تطورات لافته على مختلف
الجبهات ولعل الجبهه الشماليه اخذت حصه
الاسد من الاخبار اليوم وحينما نشير الى
الجبهه الشماليه لابد ان نلاحظ بان عمليات
القصف والاشتباكات بين المقاومه استمرت في
الجبهات الشماليه وتحديدا الشيخ رضوان
والشيخ عجين كما سنفصل كان هناك ايضا
عمليه قصف للمناطق الوسطى وتحديدا البريج
ولكن كان ايضا هناك اشتباكات وايضا عمليات
قصف لمواقع في خانيونس اي في الجبهه
الجنوبيه لو ذهبنا الى المنطقه الشماليه
والتركيز سيكون تحديدا على هذه المنطقه
منطقه التفاح والدراجه التي كان الحديث
عنها كبيرا خلال اليومين الاخيرين كتائب
القسام اعلنت عن استهداف عدد من الدبابات
دبابات الميركافا على محور التفاح الدرج
اي على هذا المحور ايضا اعلنت عن استهداف
قوه راجله دوما على مستوى محور التفاح
وذلك بعد الكمين الذي اعلنته امس وقالت
انه استهدف قوه متحصنه من او ناقله جند من
عشره جنود وانهم اردتهم كلهم قتلى من
المسافه الصفر اذا هذه جبهه متحركه
متفاعله على مستوى التفاح والدرج غير بعيد
عن هذه الجبهه نجد حي الشيخ رضوان وحينما
نتحدث عن جبهه الشيخ رضوان فاننا نشير
ايضا الى عمليات اشتباك وايضا استهداف ل
كما قالت القسام لقوه ايضا قوه متو غله في
هذا في هذه المنطقه تتشكل من 20 جنديا
وقالت انها اردت عددا منهم بين قتيل وجريح
لعل اللافت اليوم هو هذه التطورات في هذه
المنطقه وتحديدا منطقه الشيخ عجلين من
خلال اعلان كتائب القسام ايضا عن استهداف
قوه متحصنه صارت ظاهره استهداف القوى
الاسرائيليه المتحصن في في منازل سمه
ليوميات الحرب ايضا كان هناك عمليه قنص
بسلاح قنص من نوع ام 99 لجندي اسرائيلي في
هذا المحور كان ايضا استهداف لسيارتي جيب
من نوع همر في هذا الموقع اذا لدينا كما
نلاحظ ثلاث جبهات في هذه المنطقه الشماليه
نهيك عن عمليه القصف التي طالت مواقع في
جباليه جبهه شماليه ملتهبه لا تختلف عنها
كثيرا الجبهه الاخرى وهي في المناطق
الوسطى من خلال الاستهداف الذي الذي طال
بالخصوص مخيم البريج وحينما نتحدث عن مخيم
البريج نشير ايضا الى اداء المقاومه
باعلان القسام عن استهداف لست استهدافها
لست مركبات او ست اليات اسرائيليه وايضا
لعدد من الجنود كان هناك ايضا قصف بالهاون
لعدد من التحشد العسكريه في البريج على
مختلف المستويات ربما الاشاره الى عمليه
القصف لن سرات زوايده ودير البرح والمغازي
نشير ربما الجبهه الجنوبيه ظلت ايضا
ملتهبه في خان يونس ولعل حينما نشير الى
خان يونس نشير ايضا الى اشتباكات لقوات
القسام هنا في رفح لكن اللافت هو ما اعلنه
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو فيما
يتعلق بهذا المحور هو محور الفيلادلفيا
ويبلغ طوله 14 كترا حينما تحدث عن سيطره
اسرائيليه على هذا المحور ولعله يحيل الى
التساؤل من ناحيه التحليل العسكري مدى
واقعيه هذا الكلام اضافه الى التطورات
اللافته في جبهات الشمال والوسط والجنوب
ليلى بالضبط عبد القادر هذه هي النقطه
تحديدا التي سنبدا بها حوارنا اللواء فايز
اذا سمحت لي يعني محور فيلادلفيا عندما
يقول نتنياهو يجب السيطره عليه ما واقعيه
هذا يعني بدا الحديث وتحدثت انا في اليوم
الاول عندما تم الاعلان عن التحول الى
المرحله الثالثه و اعاده التموضع في نقاط
معينه انا في اول يوم تحدثت قلت ان
المنطقه العازله سي يسعى جيش الاحتلال
والقياده السياسيه في الكيان الى السيطره
على الحدود كامله الشماليه والشرقيه
والجنوبيه بالاضافه الى السيطره على عرض
معين من وادي غزه وبالتالي السيطره على ما
يعادل تقريبا الى حد ما نصف مساحه غزه لكن
بدا القتال على الواجهه الشرقيه واستمر
على الواجهه الشماليه و لم يكن اي اشارات
او حديث عن هذه المنطقه الا قبل عده ايام
عندما حاولت القوات الاسرائيليه ان تدخل
في هذه المنطقه ولكنها اصطدمت مع اي
المقاومه القسام وبقيه الفسائل والحق بها
خسائر
وتراجعت كان البيان الاسرائيلي اللاحق انه
لم تكن تهدف الى السيطره على هذه المنطقه
بقدر ما كانت هي عمليه استطلاع للبحث عن
انفاق عابره للحدود مع جمهوريه مصر
العربيه ولكن الان الان يقول هو ي في هذا
اليوم هو يتحدث لكن الان هناك مجموعه من
العوامل قد تحول دون تحقيق ذلك اولا ما هو
موقف جمهوريه مصر العربيه هناك اتفاقيه
كام ديفيد معروفه
وتحديدات معروفه اثنين هذا القطاع تم
السيطره عليه في عام ال 67 وكان تحت
الاداره المصريه وبالتالي هناك مسؤوليه
اخلاقيه ثلاث هناك معطيات يجب ان تبقى
موجوده هل
اسرائيل ستقوم
بالتنسيق ام ستقوم بالعمل منفردا هذه
عوامل خارجيه لكن تبقى هامشيه مع تقديري
لها قياسا مع قدره المقاومه على منعه من
تحقيق هذا الامر لانه بالتالي هو يقطع
تواصل غزه مع العالم بالمطلق الان معبر
رفح هو الرئه الوحيده التي تتنفس منها غزه
وهي المنطقه الوحيده التي تتواصل مع
العالم اذا قطع محور فيلادلفيا واصبح تحت
السيطره الاسرائيليه ما ماذا يعني ذلك
يعني انه اكمال الحصار بدرجه 100% ولا
اعتقد ان المقاومه اغفلت هذا هذا الاحتمال
وان حساباتها موجوده ولكن السؤال يعني بعد
الاخفاقات التي مني بها الجيش في مناطق
مختلفه لماذا يطرح الان فكره السيطره على
هذا المحور تحديدا في هذا الوقت وهو يعني
يعرف انه يحتاج ان يحسن صورته ان يحسن
صوره جيشه في هذه المرحله هو الان اي كانه
يلعب بالاوراق الاخيره في جيبه وهناك مثل
في اللغه العربيه يعني يراهن على ال
الورقه الاخيره في الجيب في جيبه المخروم
اصلا وبالتالي هناك خلاف مع امريكا حول
اطار الحرب وما هو مفهوم المرحله الثالثه
وكيف يتم الانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه
هناك خلاف واضح جدا داخل مجلس الحرب يعني
هو ووزير الدفاع على مسافه قريبه من بعضهم
البعض لكن بقيه الاعضاء زينكو والاخر
بدليل الرفض اللي حصل رفضوا ان يخرجوا معه
في المؤتمر الصحفي يعني هذا الرفض كجيش
يعني يتابع كجنود كيف يؤثر عليهم يعني
يعني دعيني اضيف جمله هو على خلاف مع رئيس
الاركان ومدير الموساد استبعدهم من جلسه
في مجلس مع وزير الدفاع يناقشوا ماذا بعد
ماذا بعد الهدنه او ما هو المست مقبل اذا
هو على خلاف اصلا مع اعلى قياده في الجيش
لماذا لانه
هذه رئيس الاركان يجب سواء كان في الجيش
الاسرائيلي يجب ان يكون على درايه بقدراته
هل هي تحقق الاهداف لان السياسي في بعض
الحالات قد قد يكون له اهداف ومارب لا
يمكن للقوات المسلحه ان تقدر على تنفيذها
وهذه هي مشكله الخلاف الان ما بين الجيش
والمسا والحديث عن الشلل السياسي بهذا
المفهوم اللي اشار اليه الجيش ولكن اذا
سمحت لي قبل ان ننتقل الى المشهد الميداني
ككل اريد فقط فيما يتعلق بمحور فلادلفيا
لان نتنياهو قبل قليل ركز عليه بشكل غير
مسبوق وكانه اصبح الهدف الذي يسعى لتحقيقه
فقط اذا سمحت لي السؤال يتعلق بالفتره
يعني هو مره جديده كرر انه نحتاج للمزيد
من الوقت تتحدث عن
شهرين يعني هل هذا في صالح الجيش هل هذا
في صالح نتنياهو و ان تطول الحرب به هو ما
هو يعني ما هي طبيعه المعارك التي هو
يتخيلها او يتحدث اذا كان يتحدث عن عده
اشهر بهذا المستوى من المعارك فجيش
الاسرائيلي غير قادر على تنفيذ ذلك ويكون
قد حفر قبره بنفسه لانه يعني س الاحراج
سيكون الفشل في 7 اكتوبر اي نقطه صغيره
تجاه الفشل الحالي يعني من من خلال اداره
المعركه وحجم القوات التي تم زجها تم زج
خمسه فرق حتى هذه اللحظه فقط حتى نذكر
المشاهدين الفرقه والفرق بينها وبين الان
الفرقه ثلاثه الويه هذا الاستاندرد
العالمي لكن في كثير من الحالات قد يكون
فيها اكثر زج بقوات النخبه وهي خارج الفرق
الخمسه هو زج بتسعه الويه اضافيه تسعه
الويه اضافيه منها الويه المشال اربعه
النخبه اذا هو دفع باكثر في القراءات الا
الاولى كان قد خ تم تخصيص 45% لكن بعد
الدفع الجديد للقوات الان هو دفع اكثر من
50% من قدرات الجيش لانه ابقى على احتياط
استراتيجي احتياط عملياتي قوات عامله في
الضفه الغربيه قوات عامله في المنطقه
الشماليه فهو الان دفع باكثر من نصف قدرات
الجيش ولم يحقق شيء هذا الامر يتناقض مع
الحديث عن البعد الاقتصادي والحديث عن
تسريح لانه هو تم دعوه 300 100 ال من
الاحتياط الان هو يريد ان يسرح اذا هذا
هذا الامر لا يمكن لا يمكنه ان يدير
المعركه بهذه الكثافه لاسابيع خصوصا و انه
يخسر الدبابه والدبابه والجراه
والجرا هذا ايضا يعني مهم ان ربما فقط
نتوقف عند المشهد ككل اليوم بالنسبه
للمناطق المختلفه فقط اذا ممكن تع قبل
الان هناك اربعه نقاط حاسمه رئيسيه الشيخ
عجلين دخلت بصوره جزئيه الى الى الى
الصوره من حيث العمليات بعد توقف اكثر من
سبعه اسابيع الشيخ رضوان لا يزال الجزء
الغربي منه تدور في معارك ضاريه وفي هذا
اليوم في عمليه واحده قتل 20 شخص منطقه
جبل الريس والشعف والتفاح والدرج معارك
ضاريه وارقام كبيره الان اذا ذهبنا الى
المنطقه الوسطى في عجاله في المنطقه الوسط
في المنطقه الوسطى لو سمحت تعطينا المنطقه
الوسطى الان تم حشد الفرقه 36 للتعامل مع
النصيرات والبريج والبقيه المنطقه حتى
الزوايده ولكن رغم ذلك لا يستطيع ان يتقدم
ل مخيم البريج تقريبا 2.5 كيلر مربع في
عصر هذا اليوم اجبرت القوه التي تحولت
الدخول الى الرجوع الى منطقه السياج الان
اذا ذهبنا
جنوبا لو سمحت
عو اذا ذهبنا للمنطقه الجنوبيه الان
القوات هناك سبعه الويه تقاتل في هذه
المنطقه طبعا هناك جزء من القوه ذهب من
القراره وعمل الاحاطه وهو على تماس الى حد
ما مع شمال
غزه القوات التي تقاتل في الشرق لا تزال
عالقه في بني سهيله حققت بعض التجاوزات في
بعض المناطق الى ما بعد ال شارع صلاح
الدين ووصلت بعض الى شارع السكه قد لا
يكون ظاهرا على الخارطه ومن ثم الان
الحديث عن محور فيلادلفيا الذي لم تبدا
المعارك فيه بعد بالضبط وهو اللي كان
المحور الاساسي اليوم في المؤتمر الصحفي
لنتنياهو على العموم لنتابع
فيديو كان قد بثته كتائب القسام
اليوم عن معارك ضاريه دارت بينه وبين
الجيش الاسرائيلي في خان
يونس نتابعه معا
استخدام اطلاق قذائف الهاون طبعا شاهدت
الفيديو قبل هذه اللحظه هناك هاون 120
ملمتر هاون اثنين بوصه يعني اعيره مختلفه
للهاون وبناء عليها يكون وزن القذيفه
والمدى الذي يصل له والتاثير المتوقع من
عمليه الانفجار لكنها تبقى فاعله ضد حشود
قوات العدو وخاصه الافراد والاليات خفيفه
التصفيح والاليات المدولبه وهنا تستخدم من
مواقع مختلفه لاحظ الان يغطي
الجدار بشرشف كما يقال كانه يطلق من ساحه
المنزل من ساحه
[موسيقى]
المنزل يعني عده نقاط وكذلك سرايا القدس
نشرت فيلم
اخر هذا الفيديو
نشاهده عزدين القسام نتابع هذا الفيديو
حصلت عليه الجزيره اذا
ل مواجهات في خان يونس هذه الدبابه
تدميرها كان يعني ملفت الانتباه القذيفه
اطلقت من داخل المنزل وهي على بعد امتار
سنلاحظ بعد الانفجار ان بعض بعض شضايا
التفجير دخلت الى داخل
المنزل هذه القطعه دخلت الى داخل المنزل
مما يعني ان الاستهداف لم يكن على مسافه
امتار خمس الى 6 متر في الحد الاقصى
دبابه المركبه التي تمر هذه الدبابه اللي
فقط ايضا نذكر يعني يعني تكلفتها يمكن 70
مليون دولار لا لا هي تكلف اقل من اقل من
ذلك يعني لا اذكر الرقم بالضبط لانه اخترت
الامور لكن هذه اللقطه هذه اللقطه هي لقطه
هذه تسجل في قد هل تستفيد منها هذه
الدبابه كانت يقف على مسافه عده امتار
من من النفق وخرج من النفق
والصق حشوه شواط وقام بتدميرها انظري الان
لاحظ لاحظي الهدوء الهدوء في تركيبها كانه
يعنيي كانه في في حصه تدريبيه حصه تدريبيه
الصقها جهزها عاد
الى الى النف ونفذ عمليه التفجير هذه فتحه
النفق التي ظهر منها من خلال سلم ارتقى
وصعد ونفذ العمليه وسال سالته قبل ذلك كيف
له هذا قلت هو يقارن بين حياتين حياه
ثانيه وحياه باقيه وبالتالي لم لم
تكن يكيد من خلال خبرتك العسكريه شاهدت
الكثير من يعني حتى ربما من
اعتى
الكثير درسنا معظم درسنا معظم الحروب خاصه
الحروب الحديث وحتى من فتره الاسكندر
الاكبر حتى الان درسناها معظمها لكن هذه
اللقطات لا هذه ستصبح ماده اكيد سبب بسيط
رغم اني جنرال اقول هؤلاء لم يدرسوا في
معاهد عسكريه ضمن ايقاع معين جاؤوا من
خارج الصندوق العسكري المعروف ببعض
الحالات في البيروقراطيه فجاء تفكيرهم
اصلا خارج الصندوق لهذا السبب يفاجئ
العالم والجيش الكوري بال بالامس اجرى
تمرين محاكاه للسابع من اكتوبر تخوفا ان
كوريا الشماليه قد تستنسخ تلك التجربه اي
هذه هذه الجرافه التي استهدفت ايضا في خان
يونس جرافه نعم هذه كمان لها قصه الجرافه
الاولى دمرت جاءت الثانيه وجاءت الث دمرت
جاءت الثالثه دمرت جاءت الرابعه دمرت فب
الاخير كان الجيش الجيش الاحتيال قال لهم
مسامحين كم بالجرافات ما رح نحاول ننقذ
لانه بقيت النيران المشتعله لمده ثلاثه
ايام فيها وتركت هكذا تركت هكذا اما ماذا
جرى بعد الثلاث ايام لا استطيع ان في كمان
اليوم كان حديث عن بندقيه استعملت بندقيه
ام
99 ام 99 هذه الصينيه طولها طولها متر ونص
مداها تقريبا
15 مؤثره المدى التاثيري قد تسدد لغايه
1600 100 متر وزنها 12 غرام على ما اعتقد
سرعه الطلقه 800 متر بالثانيه ضعف سرعه
الصوت وا 12.7 على ما اعتقد المخزن يتسع
ال خمس طلقات هذه لم يعني يمكن سمعنا عنها
مره من قبل في هذه الح لا كانت الغول كانت
الغول صناعه محليه
هذه اول مره اول مره نشاهد عن الام 99 في
هذه الحرب لاول مره نشاهد هذه هذه هذه
البندقيه للمره الاولى شاهدها وقيل انها
يعني سوريا حصلت على عليها الباكستان حصلت
عليها كيف اذا وصلت الى غزه لا يعنيني
المهم انها موجوده تبقى دائما هناك اسئله
معلقه على العموم نشكرك دائما على تحليلك
الدقيق شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء فايز دويري